welcome back well it's crank straight on
with our next guest Labour's Shadow
Attorney General Baroness Chuck Bass T
thanks very much for being with us in
studio this morning and now before we go
on to brexit in other issues I'm keen to
get your reaction to the news that our
city editor mark Kleiman broke yesterday
and that Nissa and is planning to cancel
production of its extra model in
Sunderland's concerning news it's very
very troubling and that is a region that
does not need more uncertainty turmoil
and when something like that happens you
have to think not just about the
potential jobs in that industry in that
region you have to think about the whole
supply chain - and it's places like
Sunderland that have really really
suffered for years actually since the
crash it's it's it's places like that
that we need to look to when we're
looking at you know in a sense the the
causes of the brexit vote so I'd look I
don't it's not for me to speculate until
Nissen makes its announcement about the
precise reasons but they've I think in
recent times already moved battery
manufacture and R&D you know when
looking perhaps to lose you know vital
infrastructure to to places like China
but also to to parts of the EU like
France it's it's really troubling is
there anything that the government
should be doing I think that it needs to
end uncertainty in many respects in
particular that the No Deal brexit
Sonora and I want to make everything
about bricks it because they're you know
as you discussed earlier with Vince
Cable there are other issues in in in in
car manufacturing but the no deal brexit
is an uncertainty that's completely
unacceptable for all sorts of people
farmers car manufacturers consumers the
government needs to absolutely take that
off the table I don't think that the
House of Commons will tolerate a No Deal
brexit so Teresa may it needs to stop
running down the clock and using that
terrible threat to some kind of
bargaining chip with the EU I mean the
easiest way to take no deal off the
table is to get a deal through yeah is
it
time for labor to drop some of its red
lines naturally looked and make a
compromise and get a deal well you know
that Jeremy Corbyn went in last week to
speak to Theresa mate and I know that
he's been criticized in the past for not
speaking to her earlier but it was
because he wanted no deal off the table
and then to be able to talk about what
kind of a deal might get the support
over the house you can't take no deal
off the table can you until you've got
the basis of some kind of deal I mean
it's labour who can actually take no
deal off the table by trying to get a
weave you know what Jeremy and Corbin
and Theresa may have begun to discuss
are our priorities which we think are
closer to the priorities that would
command support across the House of
Commons so that's a customs union okay
well let's talk about custody onion and
which is always which is what labor
often say you know permanent customers
yes what you want at the same time
though the backstop
has an effective customs union in it and
at the minute we haven't negotiated the
future relationship so why don't you
vote for the withdrawal agreement and
get that through which already has a
customs union in it and then argue for
the customs union afterwards because you
because you have to have some vision of
where you're going before you sequencing
isn't it you get the divorce done before
the future relationship yeah but you
know most likely with a labor version as
a future relationship that the backstop
would be much less of an issue that you
the reason for the backstop is because
the EU like labour will not countenance
a hard border the need now given where
we are and the timing for some kind of
insurance policy or backstop but the
point is we have less of a problem and
less uncertainty about the future
because we want that customs union we
want that close relationship on
regulatory alignment on a customs union
on a strong single market relationship
which would mean that they wouldn't have
to be this divergence which is what
creates the the conflict around the
backstop okay and now there's been some
criticism over Labour MPs this week who
voted for
the deal or signal that they could vote
for the deal in return potentially for
some more money for their constituencies
now if those constituencies voted to
leave the EU and they are in need of
more investment it's not a win-win no I
don't think it's a win-win and by the
way I don't believe in the end about any
Labour MP would really be fooled by you
know what some people have called a
bribe and someone and that's not because
Labour constituencies like vast parts of
the country aren't desperate for more
investment it's because you can't just
pick pick constituencies off in that
sort of very narrow way we need
investment across regions across the
country whether it's on things like
research and development whether it's
regional regional as I started and none
though isn't it look I get that I just
do not believe that labor voters and the
most left behind constituencies would
thank their MPs for these short-term
isolated bribes I just I just don't see
that commanding public confidence and
supporting when you think about how
disenchanted so many people have been
with politics and politicians in recent
years the idea that that would be that
that would be reversed by this kind of
pork barrel politics I just don't I just
don't see okay well let's talk about
something else that could potentially
cause a disenchantment in politics which
is a second referendum you spoke about
with Vince Cable earlier and I'm keen to
get your thoughts on it as well so last
week on the show and I just want to show
you what your shadow cabinet colleague
Angela Rainer said she said if we end up
with a second referendum then others
politicians have failed the public do
you agree with that I think she's got a
point I think she's got a point you know
personally I'm very very skeptical about
referenda in general because of this
binary yes/no in/out kind of approach
that that doesn't deal with nuances and
complexities and what kind of bricks it
and what kind of EU what kind of
relationship and so we had this
referendum a few years ago we didn't
have a even a qualified majority for
that level
constitutional change to simple majority
and look what happened this completely
divisive divided result mrs. may said
she was going to heal the country she
called her election that she didn't need
to call it hasn't healed the country I
think Angela has a point
and as I've said and other people have
said if you have a second referendum and
you get the same result or a slightly
different result this time this time
it's 52 48 the other way what happens
next so it could be more device than you
think
if we have another it could be I mean I
can't say we can't rule it out
altogether because if you have to break
the stalemate I personally would prefer
a general election now you might say
well you would say that wouldn't you
that's self-serving but it's just that
in a general election you get to talk
about other things you get to have
nuance you get to talk about social care
and education and and manufacturing
investment and so on and so forth things
that you don't get to talk about in a
simple in out yes/no black wire you
might get your election info reports in
the mail on Sunday or anything to go by
they say that to reason Mays pencil one
in for June what you know I hope so and
I say to her you know you you know you
did it when you didn't need to do it and
now you've been in stasis the country is
effectively not being governed all sorts
of other desperately important issues
are not being dealt with they were doing
better in the polls then because if
people don't like to reason made and
they must be looking at you guys and
thinking I want a lime one then either I
think partly I think partly let's be
honest labor is a party of leave and
remain it's not a party just of lead or
just of remain remain what unites labor
whether it's party members or MPs or
voters is a belief in social justice and
if all the energy and all the debate and
all the commentary and all the Sunday
morning TV is always about brexit
sometimes it's hard to cut through with
the kind of issues that that helped us
image in the general election campaign
that that is that is an issue but we've
done you know we've not done it I mean
can argue about polls and you know a
poll of polls and how many you've done
slightly better or slightly worse in in
you know the last a the most important
poll of all is the Democrat is the
official Democratic one which is a
general election and now before we go
I'm interested get your thoughts on
Venezuela and we've seen people taking
to the streets again you know in support
of both the president and the opposition
leader what's your take on what's
happening and how the international
community should bring that so here's
the thing when I'm not an expert in a
particular region like South America
I go to my trusted sources for for the
picture and for me as a human rights
campaign my trusted sources have always
been Amnesty International and Human
Rights Watch and I would say this to
your viewers it's always a good place to
start when you want to know what might
be happening in a country and last
year's reporting on Venezuela are pretty
damning and that's in terms of
disappearances that's in terms of
crushing dissent that's in terms of
reports of torture of prisoners and
political prisoners and it's completely
unacceptable and I think it is incumbent
on people like me you know and as
someone of the left to call out
governments and and and states of the
left because human rights have to be
applied with an even and there wasn't
Jeremy Corbyn have been tougher than do
you think on in his statements on Maduro
well I think that um I think Jeremy is a
lifelong human rights defender but of
course it sometimes it's difficult for
him to cut through in in the media
because people just say well you're a
socialist just like the Venezuelan talks
about his public statements well he mean
he has said is that we you have to have
the rule of law and you have to have
human rights and clearly if you if you
if you match that with the reporting of
the situation in Venezuela that's not
happening however and I do have to say
this it would be very helpful if the
United States and the UK conservative
government would yes of course call out
Venezuela but also look across the way
at Honduras where you have a us-backed
government that is also
dissent I think that this kind of human
rights defense on the planet only works
when we're all applying these standards
with an e with an even hand whether it's
Saudi Arabia whether it's Israel
Palestine whether it's Venezuela
whether it's Honduras and and if we
start applying these values with an eye
to oil or regime change then you know
we're always on a pretty sticky wicket I
think and we and we don't make things
better okay we're out of time thank you
very much thank you